what do you make of the level of
knowledge and rigor that scientists
approach or grapple with the question of
religion is it sufficient there are many
religions Hinduism Buddhism Judaism
Christianity Islam I think that
everybody should have some understanding
of those religions and their Origins a
little bit about their cultural history
because religion and science are the two
greatest forces that have shaped our
civilization if you don't understand the
history of religion the cultural
significance of religion then you really
have a big gap in your understanding of
who we are and who our society is